let's talk about what the definition of
consciousness is and sentience and mind
so those are consciousness sentience and
mind
yosha why don't you start with your
definitions of them then we'll hear
john's because obviously we have to
create the definitions yeah sure the
definitions i don't think that are
necessarily contentious points we just
need to
anchor them somehow so we agree on what
things we are talking about and what we
are not talking about i think so to me
mind is basically um the
vehicle in which everything plays out
it's basically the mechanism and
substrate that is
emergent over
mostly the activity of the brain i think
and inside of the mind there happens a
model of the world and the self and the
mind also facilitates motivation at some
level
and
then
the next term that we wanted to talk
about is sentience sentence is the
ability of a system to relate to its
environment and to discover itself in
the environment and establish this kind
of relationship and in this way learn
what it's doing and i don't think that
sentience is the same thing as
consciousness because for instance it
doesn't have to happen in real time
there doesn't need to be an immediate
reflexive awareness of this process
itself that is becoming aware
in a sense i think for instance that
corporations are usually not conscious i
think but many corporations are sentient
in the sense that they understand what
the corporation is how this corporation
relates to the world and how it
interacts with the world and plans for
it and of course the sentience of the
corporation is facilitated by the people
that work for the corporation in this
planning role but so sentience is a
functional properties that many
intelligent systems develop
and consciousness is
colloquially speaking the feeling of
what it's like it's a as a particular
phenomenology that is
it looks like something to the system
that is conscious and i think that
functionally consciousness is largely a
control model of the attention of the
system and when we say that a system is
conscious for instance a cat
or a human being what we mean is that
this system is able to act on a model of
its own awareness which means it knows
that it is aware of things
and uses that to drive its own behavior
in the moment
is that distinct from self-consciousness
that it's aware that it's aware
self is slightly different because you
can be conscious without having a self
for instance in dreams you will very
often
notice that you are conscious but there
is no i
and also in meditative states you don't
need to focus on the eye
what typically happens though in the
type of consciousness that we have is
that we know that something is conscious
so we are aware of the awareness but
that doesn't need to have a first-person
perspective and consciousness
so i would say that first person
perspective and consciousness even
though in our normal daytime wakeful
state are largely uh related are
actually orthogonal you can have them
independently of each other in a way
okay john so what are your definitions
or what do you agree with disagree with
well uh first of all though about the
reference before the sense um
yeah i take it to my mind to refer to
um
although whether or not it forms a
unified entity it's perhaps part of the
question but what we're referring to
mine refer referring to some
unity some system uh by which we are
intelligent and conscious
and i take intelligence to be the
capacity to be a general problem solver
and
i'm not sure
um
what
the problem i have with this in
cognitive science is the term mind is
equivocal
people use it in different ways
make different identity claims and
neuroscientists perhaps saying it's
brain function
the ai person may say it's a particular
kind of learning algorithm
the psychologist will say it's you know
that which generates behavior um and the
point about this is it's not just a
terminological difference
they use different methods of gathering
evidence they make different kinds of
arguments they have different kinds of
theoretical entities the psychologist
may talk about working memory
right uh
the ai person may talk about certain
aspects of machine learning of course
the neuroscientists may talk about
neural net on various neural networks in
the biological sense
so i take it that what i'm trying to do
as a cognitive scientist is find out if
all of those different definitions of
mind can uh work together uh to get back
to the coherent unity that we
traditionally met by the word mind so
that's part of the problem but as part
of the fun of trying to do cognitive
scientists it's often very hard
to get the anthropologist the linguist
the psychologist um
the neuroscientist and the ai person to
all agree and you put them in the room
and then usually you throw in
philosophers who are supposed to help uh
get all that discourse from running
smoothly and they often make things more
challenging which is uh makes it
especially fun um so i i largely agree
with what uh joshua said uh although i
want to problematize it
and specifically it's something that
cognitive sciences asking the question
what is mind is not a clear question
anymore and i think getting clear about
what that question is is one of the
tasks of cognitive science
so um
sentience um
an awareness and uh
um i i tend to have i tend to bind
sentience to maidson's notion of
sentience
uh
which is a way i think it might overlap
with what yoshi means by awareness but a
sentient system is one that can in some
sense size up
its situation um it it's aware of it but
not in just sort of the nebulous sense
uh right it it it can foreground in
background information
things like that
so perhaps i think a little bit of a
tighter connection between sentience and
perceptual awareness
consciousness
consciousness
[Music]
there's usually sort of two aspects and
of course there's a all of this
everything i'm saying here is fraught
and yoshi knows this right uh people
talk about two aspects of consciousness
there's one
aspect it's often called access
consciousness this is part of what
consciousness means is my
i can ready things i can make things
ready for a reason i can make them ready
for problem solving um
and i can bring aspects of my you know
of my skills and my perception and my
understanding together
um
and then there's what's called the
phenomenal some people say
phenomenological there's a bit of
confusion around that
but anyways as usual said this is the
feeling of what it's like what it's like
to be me here now in this situation it
could mean that it can mean something
very primitive like what is it like to
experience green and this is the
so-called problem of qualia
and so one way people think of
consciousness is the the place where
qualia exists
um
for me there's two central questions we
we are asking
and part of what i would argue is we
need to integrate them together and one
of the the strengths i see of yoshi's
work is i do see him attempting and i
don't mean attempting as a as an insult
we're all attempting here um
attempting to integrate these two
questions together one is the function
question which is basically what the
hell does consciousness do
given that so much
so much of our intelligent behavior
happens unconsciously what is
consciousness for some people are
willing to say it's not for anything
it's just an epiphenomenon it doesn't do
anything it has no function yoshi
doesn't say that i'm not saying he does
the other question is the nature problem
how is it that something like
consciousness exists in this physical
world which
amongst all these objects that don't
seem to have any of these subjective uh
properties qualia
things like that at least since the
scientific revolution we separated all
of those out from uh the physical
universe and we put them in this place
now i happen to think that you should
try and answer those questions together
in an integrated fashion
one of the criticisms i have of some of
the central theories is they tend to
answer one question
while neglecting the other and vice
versa um
so i think that's
my
best i had to say a little bit more
because he went first so i had to sort
of take into what yoshi said
but that's
trying to answer
any good definition of consciousness
should try and answer the function and
the nature questions in an integrated
fashion